so some colorful characters on that
invitation list to the White House and
apparently the Vatican isn't so pleased
yeah I think there's some concern about
the affiliations of some of the
individuals there particularly
pro-choice individuals people that don't
necessarily work in lockstep with the
Vatican's perspective on some of the key
tenets of the Church's teaching when you
talk to White House officials about this
their point is this they're going to be
15,000 people on the White House lawn
for the Pope's arrival ceremony on the
twenty-third and so it's more that
there's just a large group of people
they're not controlling everybody's
there they're saying that there's no
intended slight to the Vatican with this
move but as you said Bonnie I think
there's been recognition of it at the
Vatican right now and there's some
concern at least a little bit of concern
here because one of the biggest problems
with this visit at least potential
problems is that this becomes political
I think that's what everybody's trying
to avoid but more and more is we've
become closer to this gotten close to
this trip those problems are starting to
arise but as you well know Phil
everything is political and this Pope is
definitely a Democrat what does the
White House want politically out of this
visit you are convinced one hundred
percent that this Pope is a Democrat
that's I i I'm gonna have to check the
Vatican for comment on that Brendan look
I think when you talk to White House
officials about this visit first up
they're very excited you remember back
march in 2014 the president had a
one-on-one with Pope Francis and it was
one that he referenced over and over
again in press conferences in public
remarks for pretty much the next six
months it had a real impact on him but
more importantly I think he sees Pope
Francis is somebody who can help push
initiatives for the White House you talk
about things getting political the Pope
obviously speaking out on climate change
speaking out on inequality those are
issues the White House wants to seize on
and move forward with but there are
issues obviously the White House breaks
with when it comes to abortion the Pope
is called out pretty much the entire
international community on Syria which
has been a major weakness for the White
House so I think the White House is
cautious because they know that they
can't control what he's going to say
he's going to say things over the next
week that maybe they don't necessarily
agree with but they're going to try and
take the things that they agree with and
use them to move forward on their agenda
guys who would have been in charge of
actually deciding who the invitees were
Phil and did the White House really
invite 15,000 people or is that just the
number that's going to turn up
it was so it worked a couple of ways
there's a chief of protocol who I feel
so bad for based on having to plan for
this over the last couple months they
reached out to organizations that that
were prominent in the arena and not just
Catholic kind of across the religious
spectrum from Hindu Muslim other
Christian organizations and so that's
been kind of the driving force behind
the visit one of the interesting things
guys I think about this visit in its
entirety is the top tier lawmakers and
administration officials that are
Catholic vaani you have to think about a
vice president joe biden Catholic House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi Catholic
House Speaker John Boehner Catholic so a
lot of Catholics very excited about this
visit guest